d'aller au cap horn et d'y aller en
sanitaire parce que dans le domaine des
choses de la mer et de la voile c'est le
rêve et ce vers quoi on se dit qu'un
jour on on ira c'est le horn et leur ne
seul face à face
maintenant je sens que le moment est
venu du lait je me sens frais
psychologiquement prêt physiquement prêt
le bateau j'ai pu le préparer alors
maintenant je parle pour le gabon si je
pars à la même époque sicap à 36 époque
pour partir dans ces régions là il y a
un enchaînement des bonnes saisons sur
le plan météorologique
et il convient de partir à l'automne
naturellement j'aurais pu partir quinze
jours plus tôt 15 jours plus tard mais
l'occasion est fabuleuse de voir
comment porter mes efforts
d'amélioration du bateau en
emmenant métallos n'en sommes tout sur
le trajet de l'atlantique qui va être de
la mettre en commun avec ses ouailles de
la pop anglaise et surtout que j'ai
d'ailleurs la tête la préparation de la
prochaine transat chez gagne à newport
l'an dernier la transat a lieu tous les
quatre ans en 76 jeu sera un nouveau
départ avec la ferme intention de tenter
et de réaliser le doublé de la trois
années pourquoi avoir choisi lorient
pour la préparation et saint-malo pour
le débat
parce que c'est ah si j'ai choisi
lorient pour la préparation c'est que là
bas je pouvais retrouver les
techniciennes y avait présidé à la à
l'étude et à la réalisation de ce bateau
et et puis s'il a également que se
trouve le met le maître voiliers qui
fait la garde-robe du bateau donc tout
un ensemble de conditions techniques et
puis cela un deuxième temps je suis venu
pour le mon départ de saint malo c'est
pour me retrouver dans la tradition cap
hornière saint malo origines vieille
cité où les modèles cap horn ont un sens
c'est ici le siège de l'amicale et
capitaines au long cours cap hornier qui
m'a fait le banc teneur de compte et ses
membres honoraires à mon retour 2-3
atlantique et je suis si bien connaître
sous leurs ailes protectrices vos
premiers pas ajoutez à ça une
considération dans familiale et à mon
grand frère qui habite juste en face à
dinard alors je croyais moi que c'est
drôlement pratique
qui gagna le gros sac d'une journée là
il va s'agir avant tout de penser à la
sécurité et c'est en grande partie
pourquoi à sydney j'attendrai les
concurrents de la course
classique et brody web
un passage le groupe est dur jamais dans
l'histoire de la voile on a eu une telle
chance une telle opportunité
d'affronter le poids le plus dur du
monde à la voile dans les conditions
possible fin 2004 est devenu manureva
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut aussi dire qu'il pense à vous en
même temps
nous
raté
m
ton corps
humain